my name is Matt where I am a freelance
Android developer just currently doing a
bunch of different projects right now
and loving it so I've been doing Android
for about five years and I've never been
into design really so I've just recently
got into design and I'm super excited to
kind of share what I've been learning so
I guess we should jump in here is
everyone here a developer is anyone a
designer would you say awesome do you
sketch you do you alright great so
sketch three if you don't know is a
design tool from Bohemia encoders that
it's kind of sweeping the industry right
now it's a screen design tool so it's
basically just for static screens and
final assets or mock-ups it's not a
interaction design so it doesn't do
motion like pixate and it's it's very
geared towards screen design so you know
it's it's not if you need to manipulate
a photo to make it to airbrush it or
something it's not going to be as good
as Photoshop but it's going to be a
thousand times better at designing an
appt than photoshop is in my opinion and
a lot cheaper so why talk about sketch
at all and and I think that this quote
from Roman Nurik really kind of sums it
up of why I think this is an important
topic and that's designer as chief
curator and I think this is the way
we're seeing teams work more and more
that everyone is kind of bringing ideas
together and the designer is the
guardrails and make sure you know what
is getting put out there is really
cohesive and solves the problem on a lot
of agile teams I think most people would
say they're doing agile I I noticed that
the designer is still kind of he's not
embedded or included as much as they
should be she's often times kind of
given the
and maybe there's a design meeting where
everyone comes together and reviews the
mocks or maybe there's not maybe
everyone just kind of comes together and
the designs get handed to you after the
spec goes to to the designer and the
problem with that is maybe it's good up
front and in the design meeting everyone
thinks oh this looks great you know we
can do this right away but then once you
actually start programming it you
realize this is maybe a little
impossible and so you have to go back to
the designer and say oh yeah this was
kind of messed up here what not well
they've moved on to something else
potentially and the problem is not in
their head anymore and they've just got
to solve it really quick and get it back
to you so they can continue working on
their thing and usually the problem
doesn't get solved in the cohesive way
that it was solved the first time and
designer is curator puts the
responsibility to design on everyone so
everyone understands the design problem
everyone can actually contribute mocks
and contribute assets and I've kind of
seen that designers that are embedded in
design team in development teams where
developers are also contributing the end
product is much more rich designers
unfortunately in the Android world you
probably notice if you have an Android
specific designer I think you're kind of
in the fortunate minority but most of us
are designers carry iphones they aren't
familiar with the coolest Android apps
and the interactions within those apps
and it's just it's up to us to really
advocate for Android and make sure we
don't just have a port from the iOS app
or something that looks more like a
website or whatnot so designer is chief
curator I think it's a really important
concept I heard Roman Nurik say it
recently and I think that's why we
should care about tools like sketch
where we can actually contribute more
also you know if you want to build an
app on your own it's very hard without a
designer and maybe this will empower you
a little bit more so let's jump in here
so if you only pay attention for the
next five minutes I say pay attention or
if you're
going to play if you got five minutes to
pay attention to this talk pay attention
for the next five minutes and you might
have enough to actually be dangerous and
sketch so what we're going to do is just
kind of get Sketch up and running and
open an android template where we can
just drag and drop android components
and beat and you in actually create
something so the first thing you're
going to need to do Oh magic move is
install Roboto Roboto is the font
Android uses I'm sure you're very
familiar with it no dough if it's a non
Roberto's grip but I like to get it from
here this google.com 4 / fonts it gives
you the option to put in all the
different styles and weights that you
want and it'll download all the it'll
download a zip which will be a bunch of
TTF files which is a font file and
you'll just go into the font installer
for the Mac sketch is only for Mac so if
you have a Windows machine I'm sorry for
more reasons than just that but you you
can install your fonts here and then
you'll open sketch you'll go to file new
from template and just built in straight
from sketch you can select material
design template and you'll just you'll
get this really cool artboard cheat here
it's basically just a page and it will
have just everything to spec typography
the system icons the metrics the key
lines default themes components global
elements like system icons and dialogues
just all kinds of great things that you
can just easily select from right here
and paste right into your artboard what
I like to do is and we're going to go
into all this a little more depth but I
like to select create a new page from my
sticker sheet and then create an
artboard which is just basically a
screen and built-in material design has
you know mobile portrait mobile
landscape tablet 7 inch tablet on edge
you just select one of these you can
even build a website and material are an
iOS app if you really
Metro your counterparts and just create
an artboard and so you'll just have this
on your canvas here you can go back to
your sticker sheet select something I
have selected a screen here paste it in
bam you got an app you could export it
and go to town make a million dollars
off of your cool app probably not but
you can kind of get the picture here
super easy just to get started so if you
want to download sketch it's ninety-nine
dollars search for a promo code first
you probably save twenty percent and you
can get going here that's very cool but
you know in order to build something
really engaging something that really
stands out on the android platform are
fits cohesively within the system you're
going to need to understand material
extremely well in what parts of material
are going to need to understand for
sketch not as much of the motion
although it's important for developing a
great app you will need to understand
the colors and the typography and just
basically everything that's going to be
on a static screen very well so the
first topic that is going to be really
important when you're going to start a
design is going to be what colors you're
going to use so you know the spec says
that you need to use bold hues
juxtaposed with muted environments deep
shadows bright highlights and what that
comes down to is you'll have a bunch of
different colors so you'll you'll open
up all the color palettes this is indigo
here with a pink accent and you'll want
to pick 33 of main colors from the
palette from from the main palette and
you want to pick one color from an
accident palette and what I like to do
is just you know I'm sorry so I thought
there was a question but what I like to
do is just try to get a feel for what
kind of app I'm making is it it's
serious is it more playful if it's more
playful I'll probably use a brighter
color if it's more more serious or the
content really shines out I'll probably
use a more muted color
but a bold color on a muted environment
pick three three colors and just play
around with which colors you pick tech
typography is very important and the
color that you pick under your
typography the spec lays this out very
clearly if it's light text if it's a
light background you know you want to
pick a darker darker text if it's a dark
background you pick a lighter text if
it's emphasized you don't want to put
any transparency on the text if it is
just kind of like a subtitle or
something you might want to put a little
transparency on the text imagery so
imagery is obviously very important it's
a powerful tool to help you communicate
and differentiate your product you want
to use bold graphics intentional imagery
helps to engage a user apps that have a
bunch of images and them you want to use
them more you know so you know you want
to be very intentional with what kind of
images you choose and you want to choose
ones that are contextual to your
experience if you have a travel app you
you want to show pictures of your actual
destination city if you're showing like
a plane ride or whatnot if you're
showing user information try to show a
picture of that actual user instead of
just like random person you know that
seems contrived but just you can always
kind of think contextually what kind of
images can I show here what can I not
and there's a lot of rules around images
and material design you can use multiple
mediums so if you you don't have a bunch
of actual photography it's okay to mix
in artwork and drawings so if you know
if you've got a profile picture you
don't have to just use a picture of that
person if you don't have it it's okay to
mix it and show a drawing of the person
so but just really contextual to your
experience immersive you know if it's if
it's a big hero image have it bleed all
the way to the edge and things like that
so you can really humanize a nap by the
imagery that's in it
in typography typography is just such a
huge topic so it's really hard to go
over everything right now but you know
you just know the the fonts that you
want to use generally it's going to be
rabote oh no dough because you get those
for free and you don't have to get
licenses for them they match on the
system they're optimized for the system
so they'll be able to render them the
fastest and whatnot but uh you know just
make sure to use that and kind of kind
of look over the the typography spec and
learn a little bit about what you're
doing so all right here's the meat who
is ready I can just sense it in this
room just like everyone yes that's what
I'm talking about sketch sketch is made
by bohemian coders like I said sketch
three it came out a few years ago it
just won the Apple Design Award and it's
just a great tool for screen design so
we'll just jump right in as you can see
if when you open up sketch this is what
you'll see this is a blank document
right here what's one of the one of the
first things I notice is it's not a
cockpit you know there's not a million
things like when you open photoshop
photoshop i probably tried to learn
about 3,000 times and I fail every
single time because I'm just like I need
to copy and paste this and I look up a
tutorial I'm like why do I even have to
look up a tutorial it's copy and paste
and then you know 30 minutes later I
just like have flipped my table over and
poured gasoline on my computer and I
just saved given up so it's tough crowd
no it's just terrible jokes the top menu
here is what you'll see it's not not a
lot of tools but here's the toolbar
we'll go over all these tools here in a
minute in the middle you have this
infinite canvas it goes out infinitely
so if you ever lose your document or
what you're working on you can hit
command one or even better you can go to
the View menu and hit center canvas
actually that's not better use the key
command on the left here you have your
layer list this will help keep your
document organized as you add add shapes
and group them together and ungroup them
whatnot and on the right you have your
inspector and depending on what type of
layer you have selected you'll have
different attributes that you can edit
and I got to say it's extremely powerful
and sketch even though you don't have as
many options or abilities in Photoshop
the inspector to adjust colors and and
everything is a is quite powerful so you
pretty much have everything you need
I've never met a designer who's using
sketch and their day to day for app
developer app design that can't do
something that they used to be able to
do in Photoshop they're usually doing it
much faster and especially with some of
the integrations I'm going to talk about
later much more productive and the
developers can be involved so just a to
go over the toolbar overview here and
the top left you have your insert menu
and these are going to be your objects
that you generally place on the canvas
when you look at any app and I don't
know why this eluded me for so long or
any software really it's just a bunch of
rectangles you know and that's what
you'll be using a lot you they're just
styled rectangles they have images on
them ingredients and and whatnot so
you'll come here to this menu you'll
pick a shape and you'll pick a rectangle
and draw whatnot or an oval our other
shapes sometimes you have other shapes
and whatnot but overall you have a
vector which will be you can draw kind
of anything you want and make the line
go any which way you have a pencil which
should be able to wacom or something you
could draw I'm not talented enough to
draw
but I can't make an appt kind of text
obviously a bitmap artboards which i
showed you earlier or just basically can
screens that you can use a slice to help
export graphics and a symbol which we'll
talk about here in a minute and style
text so here I drew a rectangle you can
kind of see what it would look like on
the canvas kind of get you oriented to
sketch a little bit group and ungroup
this will help you kind of keep
everything organized if you if you make
say a toolbar at the top and it's got a
you know a rectangle for the toolbar and
and icons for all the menu items and a
home screen and whatnot you might you
might get on organized so you might want
to select all those things and hit group
and then in your layer list you'll just
see one group that says toolbar and you
could drill down into it think of it
kind of like a package in Java create
symbol extremely powerful tool I like to
think of this is kind of like creating
an object are creating a class in Java
where you can reuse it everywhere and
when you need to change something in it
its behavior you can change it in one
place and it happens everywhere and
we'll go into this a little bit deeper
but just know it's it's a way when
you're exporting graphics that you can
keep everything organized and kind of in
sync zoom obviously like I said if you
get lost in the infinite canvas the
infinite abyss of your canvas you can
just quickly hit command one get
everything centered these are kind of
your standard tools here you have an
edit where you can you know move around
your tools your transform it as in sku
it rotate and flatten one kind of thing
to keep in mind with transform which
which is kind of a hole in sketch I feel
like but say you had a a group of a
rectangle and had text on it you can't
actually transform a group you can only
transform individual shapes I really
wish that you could you know put text I
was trying to put like a cover flow
album together one time where you would
have like an album in the middle and you
would swipe it and it would kind of you
know transform out
and I had text on it I couldn't actually
transform the text on top of the ranked
angle at the same time had to do them
separately I thought that was kind of
annoying so maybe that's a little hole
in sketch but overall it's great here's
a mask and scale mask is generally great
if you want a bitmap to fit around a
certain shape so who's done graphics
programming on Android oh great so you
you know you probably used my mask and
what by like clipping a shape together
clipping a path to it a bitmap here are
your boolean operations we're going to
go into these a little more in depth
later but they are just extremely
powerful for creating icons and and
whatnot especially in material you'll
notice that icons are oftentimes very
flat that's the style they're supposed
to face forward and not supposed to have
depth most more we're just made up with
a bunch of polygons that you put
together and you intersect in a union
and I know that like seems kind of
obvious but to me it was like magic when
I learned that oh wow this this clock is
just like four ovals and four rectangles
and their position together so very cool
we'll go over that in a minute move
things forward and backwards so like
this circle here is on top of the square
if i move the circle backwards then it
would be covered the square would be
covering the circle pretty standard
stuff and interacting with layers so you
can select a layer and it will show its
handles you can resize by dragging a
handle you can use the arrow keys I
think this is pretty cool you can use
the arrow keys and move it you know if
you hit the left arrow to move it to the
left x 1 pixel if you hit the right key
to move it to the right x 1 pixel if you
hit shift and you hold the arrow key
it'll move it by 10 pixels which is
pretty nice but embedded in that little
statement there is something that's kind
of cool and you get to design in pixels
you don't have to do any math you just
design an mdpi and when you need to move
something over a little bit you just
move it by a pixel and everything gets
scaled up when you export and I'll show
you how to do that here in a minute but
I think that's very nice you can develop
in a different density
if you want you can do you can develop
design and xx hdpi you just have to do
more math I just like the the pixels and
that's pretty cool I think so keep
moving along here oh yeah and you know
if you if you need to actually move an
object or a layer by a specific amount
that's kind of a strange amount you
don't have to use your mouse to drag it
by that amount you can actually put
expressions in your inspector right here
like so I put plus 13 right here and it
moved it over to the right by 13 and if
I needed to move it 13 also down I could
do that that's really helpful for when
you have two layers you need to move
them at the same amount and you can put
expressions in there I think that's very
cool you can also duplicate a layer
which becomes very powerful as we'll see
when we're creating an icon here in a
minute you can hide and show a layer as
you see this little eyeball here that's
pretty helpful if you you've got a very
busy design and you need to focus on
this one little piece here you'll hide a
bunch of layers it's a pretty standard
tool and most design tools but I just
kind of want to give an overview and you
can lock a layer this is really
important for background layers is what
I find because you know everything is
going to be on top of the background
layer and when you start selecting
around with your mouse you'll often
times accidentally select your
background layer and move it and then
it's in the wrong spot and you have to
control Z and blah blah so very
important to lock the background layer
or any layer that you don't want moved
while you're moving stuff around so just
a continuing with that interacting with
layers here as as you can see I've
grouped these two this oval and this
rectangle here and it creates a folder
on the on the layer list kind of keeps
it organized and here's my inspector if
I select a layer I get all kinds of
options I can put a an inner shadow and
outer shadow a border fill all the
various join types can be edited here
which are kind of a complex way to say
like how it's
drawn together when you intersect our
boolean objects and you can edit the
colors by dragging you can select a
color with an eyedropper just the the
power of their inspector is really
incredible for how cheap this tool is
and and in just that it's such a new
tool they've really got everything
covered a Gaussian blur they don't have
a lot of different filter types you can
put on an object so a filter type would
be like I filled this circle here with
red but I could do it like a Gaussian
blur and it would put a gradient in a
certain way we kind of look fuzzy well
you can also put a texture on it and
there's not a lot of textures and sketch
so if you if you needed like a special
texture you might actually have to use
photoshop in that way they only have
like very basic one boolean operations
so this is kind of what I was talking
about where when you need to develop
something like an icon and how they're
just polygons that you kind of put
together so you have Union which will
just take two objects and put them
together and the left will win out and
it'll be the same color you have a
subtract which will take whatever is on
top and and erase that from what's ever
on the bottom there's an intersect I
think that one's pretty obvious you know
you remember set theory and there's a
difference which it basically does the
same thing as a union but on the on the
right so actually i might have said that
wrong for difference but but here's
something i made here with boolean
operations does anyone know what this is
yes it's a clock I got it right people
knew it's awesome so yeah like I said
this is just for circles and four
rectangles what i did was i just created
a an oval here it's just a filled it
with black remove the border and then i
made a copy of it so i made a copy of
that oval its same size right on top and
i went in the inspector and just resized
it about 20 pixels down
so you can't see it because it's it's
also filled here but there's another
circle in the middle that's it's black
and then I Union them together I select
both ovals and I you knew them together
and it creates the outer rim then i've
made a copy of the big circle and scaled
it down moved it up to the right made
another copy move it over to the left
and i just moved my hands to the right
and said to the left that's awesome and
was able to Union those together and now
I have what looks like a mouse made two
rectangles on the bottom Union those
together and now I have my two legs and
then made two rectangles in the middle
that are the same size I resize the one
on top and then hit the rotate button
select it hit the rotate button as you
can see there's a little target at the
bottom of the hand that'll show up right
in the middle actually of the object
when you hit rotate you can just drag it
with your mouse all the way to the
bottom and just type in 45 degrees or 15
degrees or whatever angle you want to
rotate that and then it'll rotate it at
the new point instead of rotating it in
the middle pretty cool and you rotate it
you union it change the radius and you
have an awesome alarm clock that you can
export and put in your menu item for
setting an alarm and you can the the
range of icons you can make which is
simple polygons is incredible and
there's lots of great blog posts about
how to do this and it's a lot of fun so
I remember I told you earlier about
creating symbols symbols are really
important because often times you'll
have a symbol like say this alarm clock
was used on five different screens in my
app I can make a copy of it and then I
would have it in five different places
and then we could go to the design
meeting and the and the designer is
chief curator be like Matt I'm really
impressed I'm actually a little frayed
I'm gonna lose my job here but you made
this great alarm clock and it needs to
be edited a little bit can you go edit
all of them so if i created a symbol by
just clicking create symbol here it'll
it'll turn this alarm clock in it
purple in my lair list and that means i
can insert this symbol anywhere else in
my document so let's say i did it right
i inserted this symbol symbol in five
different places if i edit any one of
those symbols it will update all of them
it's very powerful it's you know that's
why I say it's like it's good
object-oriented design in design so very
important mask like like I said if you
need to clip a bitmap to a shape it's
really handy as we'll see here here is
our favorite designer at Google Marty
Stuart day in his awesome shirts that
cost three hundred dollars i looked up
because i wanted one I'm like three
hundred dollars kind of expensive so
I'll just stick with old navy so as you
can see here in my lair list I've got a
bit map on the back mortuus duarte say
that eight times really fast and I have
a little rectangle in the front and in
my design I only have the room for the
rectangle for the bitmap so what I need
to do is select both of these as I have
done you can seem highlighted in the
layer list and resize that bitmap and as
you can see what you see now that I've
masted the bitmap of Martius duarte is
in the middle here and that's actually
the rectangle that I clipped you and the
bitmap is still kind of visible on the
outside with the rectangle and I can
resize those corners and and you just
kind of have to picture that there's a
little window you're looking through to
see the bitmap as you're moving it
around so just really powerful for like
if you needed a profile picture in the
shape of a circle you would just draw an
oval and put the bitmap behind it and
then mask them and then you can move it
around and get it right in the face
although when you go to develop it the
bitmap never looks right and like the
face is half cut off and then you got to
use the facial recognition but then it's
slow and I'm just kidding my jokes are
great today
let's see here text so like I said text
is a huge subject but I found two really
helpful things would text the first was
so I I developed a a nap recently was a
children's cartoon and they had a very
small budget so I got to do the design i
got paid to do design for the first time
in my life i was ecstatic and I I came
and I presented my design to their head
designer because he didn't have time to
do it and he said you know this is great
but your text is just all over the place
i had ten different text sizes and they
were all different fonts and in weights
and styles and and he's like uh here's
what i would do and i'm an expert
designer so you should listen to me pic
three pick three styles and just see if
you can make the whole design with that
and if you if you can't if you need a
fourth that's fine if you can only do it
with two that's even better but just
having that idea like every time I went
to go make new textile had a new style
so just limiting it to three and then
the other one is to create shared shared
styles and we shared styles you you know
you basically have to think of about it
like styles in android if you know
you're going to use a header style
everywhere you want to you want to when
you create your text go over to the
inspector menu here and create a style
as you can see how header style for this
style and then when you're out
developing something else you can select
the the new text that you're doing and
then come here in the inspector menu and
like I said I've got footer textures
another style it'll actually show you
what it looks like in the inspector and
I choose a header textile here and I can
reuse my Styles really powerful and one
one minor thing with text when you
insert text you can do it as auto and
that means that when you type your text
it'll just keep going all the way out to
the right if you hit a new line it will
come back this way and you can type
again or you can have it fixed link then
you just drag a rectangle and as you
type it will automatically do
line breaks on the end so if you know in
your design I only want this text to
take up two hundred dips or 200 pixels
then you will just make it fixed
exporting exporting is my favorite topic
I don't know why maybe because like I
always had to ask people to export for
me and they would take a long time and I
would just have to go surf the internet
I had no other choice so I guess I had
other choices but so exporting it's a
big topic so we'll just start with
slices and you'll see this little knife
here in your layer list and if that's
highlighted you can see all of your
slices in your layer list I don't have
any slices right now so we don't see any
but you want to make sure that's
highlighted if you want to be able to
see them so to insert a slice you'll
just come here to your insert menu and
you'll select slice and that will give
you a little rectangle that you can drag
around and you just kind of get it
perfect on what you want to slice and
once you once you drop it that will
create a slice but what you'll notice
here is you know I've got this purple
background I don't want to export the
purple background I just want the icon
because it's awesome so I I need to
select this export group contents only
but the problem with that is i haven't
organized my document in my lair list in
such a way where i can easily move where
i can wear that is actually a layer
separate from my background with which i
can only export that groups contacts so
i just need to reorganize my layers over
here on the left as you can see i put
the background rectangle outside of my
group of icons and then i can select
this export group contents only and as
you see the preview shows that there's
no purple background that's being
exported so like i said this here's the
actual children's cartoon that I did app
and you know the first episode is free
and then you scroll down and the other
ones were 199 and you know I designed
this whole thing I presented it it got
accepted great all right now I get to
develop it in
I need to export these graphics so I
searched around on the web to kind of
come up with a good strategy to export
designs mostly so I could present it
here but also just because I want to be
a good designer and I came up with this
strategy from reading various blog posts
that what a lot of people like to do is
they like to create a new page called
exports you see my pages here in my lair
list so I create a page called exports
and then I add an artboard to it that's
a big art board so I put an a4 size and
i renamed it to rez so whatever your
artboard name is when you export it'll
put them in that folder so i put res
because that's what's going to be an
android studio and you know i created
symbols for my play button in my
disabled play button because those are
used everywhere and when i update them I
want them to update everywhere and i
created a bunch of slices for all the
other graphics for the logo for all of
my episodes for my background and i
select all those just by you know
hitting shift and clicking on all my
layers and then i can go down you see
there's an export menu available on the
bottom right now and all i do is i just
go down here and it's so this tool if
there's anything that's wrong with it
it's a little more geared to iOS you
have this mirror option here up in the
toolbar that i didn't discuss about but
that's the mirrior designer an iOS
device so you know I spite that icon
every time I look at it but anyway so
now I love iOS actually I used an iphone
once but then I had to go back to
Android right away and so I have an
export menu here and what I'm saying is
I want to export all these graphics at
1x sighs and I want to append put a
suffix on the end of mdpi for that file
and then I want one that's 1.5 which is
hdpi so I the file needs to be named
hdpi and a 2x and 3x with the
corresponding density and then I just
hit export and it puts all those those
files in one folder so I've got four of
each one of my of files that
exported which isn't great for Android
studio right because you need them named
a certain way so I have it I have this
quick shell script here that I just
pasted to wherever I put it in this case
the desktop I switch directory to the
desktop and I just go through and I name
all the xxhdpi s and put them in a
drawable dot X ahsti folder and the same
with all the other densities and then I
just have one res folder with all of my
density folders I drop it right in
Android studio and bam I'm ready to
develop I got this idea from this link
here at the bottom of the slide but
there's actually an even better way to
do this and everyone who is using sketch
in their design process should
absolutely be using this because it's
awesome and that is unless you don't
want to that is Zeppelin Zeppelin is a a
tool to help designers and developers
collaborate it's amazing so you can
download it it's a sketch plugin and so
when you go to export instead of doing
the whole menu like I did earlier all
you do is come up here to plugins and
hit X export selected artboards and then
you'll open up zeppelin you can it has a
web interface if someone doesn't have a
mac but this is the mac app and you can
see all the artboards that you've
exported for this project so i'll jump
in here to the the res artboard and you
can put comments so i put a comment here
make sure to put this without a margin
so your designer could do that if you
didn't understand you could respond
it'll give you a notification you can
respond it's a great way to collaborate
but you can you can see all of your
assets here you can see the colors that
are involved and whatnot probably the
most powerful feature I've found as you
can see the exported screen and you can
just kind of hover around with your
mouse and you can see exactly how many
dips each piece is apart from each other
I am I have been grown so weary of like
contacting designers to make sure I've
got the right spacing and whatnot
obviously a lot of times I just kind of
eyeball it but this is amazing the
designer is an expert at what they're
doing they're getting paid a lot of
money on you
they're crucial aspect and they know how
much they want things spaced and now you
can just easily come here to Zeppelin
and kind of hover around and see how
much space is between everything how big
icons are and what not and you can just
click on the assets tab and it will
automatically let you download all of
the exported assets for every DPI and
put them straight into Android studio
this tool is just so powerful I highly
recommend it but so just kind of an
overview of what we did today we we we
talked about what sketches we did a
quick and dirty how to get into sketch
and do a material template and pull
things into an art board and kind of
have something that's kind of working
and then we went into a deep dive of all
the features of sketch and and how to
navigate it and what to do with those
quick and dirty pieces you pulled in and
then how to export it and get it into
Android studio so that you can create a
great app or contribute in a design
meeting so I really appreciate everyone
listening today and I hope that if you
have any questions contact me on Twitter
I'm parallel cross or there's my email
and hopefully we can hopefully you will
have gained a little more interest in
sketch and maybe it'll help you one day
and communicating with your designers so
appreciate it
are there any questions yes yeah right
yeah so the question was like when
you're dragging around something in
sketch how about I open sketch here and
we'll just do it so I've open sketch so
the question was basically like you know
say i've created a rectangle and say
I've created an oval just by hitting 0
and X and like I need to like organize
these so they're lined up and you can
see there's guidelines as you like move
stuff around so you can see how like
sometimes it can be hard with the mouse
because the mouse isn't super precise so
one thing you can do is select multiple
objects and you have this little menu up
here gotta hit shift in the in the right
that'll help you kind of a line thing so
these are both of the line them to the
left side the middle you know to the
right the tops are aligned and stuff
like that so and obviously you can look
at the inspector to and see okay this
one is 286 high and you know I need it
to be 290 so you plus 4 and then you can
make this one 290 also now they're the
same size but they're not necessarily
lined up so you know you want to select
it here and line their tops and the same
so pretty cool and of course the
questioner said they've only played with
her for 15 minutes it's a very intuitive
tool and you know you run into that
little things like that all the time and
it's pretty easy to figure out so yes
I I haven't gone too deep so the
question was what other plugins besides
Zeppelin do I use I haven't gone too
deep into other plugins but the plugins
around sketch or numerous I mean there
are so many that you can use and like
its built-in see if you come file here
new from template you can pick material
design iOS you know web and and all that
and you can actually export all your
Styles built-in to CSS but I'm there's
tons of other plugins to that you could
use them that's built in but you there's
other plugins anyone else yes yeah
that's a good question it I don't know
if I have a good one or not but you know
one thing that I like to do is just kind
of it's like you're reading a book you
know what happens first is top left
corner and then as it happens it goes
bottom down right and that's how I
organize it but I don't know there's
probably better strategies that's a good
question but the question was how do you
organize your Art boards and that's my
strategy just like reading a book top
two left so like say there's a the first
screen is a it's a master-detail and you
know there's a list on the first screen
I would put my detail to the right of it
and then if you scroll down to that it
might go down one on that level but I
don't have a good strategy honestly
yeah that's a good point yes sir yes I
so the question was do you use different
Art boards four different screens and
that that's exactly what I do so I like
insert and art board you can actually
just click on the canvas and hit a and
so all so i'll put a portrait here and
let's say this one's and i can rename it
here in the menus and master i can
either just copy it here with control
paste and it'll move one over or i could
just you know click on the canvas again
and hit a and then pick another one and
we'll put it there and i could rename
this one detail so and then you know
pace whatever I want there and whatnot
so i am not a designer at all so this is
really a powerful tool to be able to get
in here really quickly yes sir are you a
designer I apologize he said yes
e
Oh awesome that's great man that's
really cool that you're doing that hard
yeah so the question was is it easier to
use than photoshop or illustrator and I
think for screen design it's way easier
but that's just from personal experience
of trying to learn illustrator and
trying to learn photoshop and failing
miserably every time so I was able to
pick this tool up in an afternoon where
photoshop and illustrator I've tried
dozens of times to do simple things and
I fail miserably so so I think it's I
think it meets the use case a lot better
of like designing a screen than
photoshop I think if you're going to
like brush up you know skin or something
then it might be a lot harder than
photoshop or if you're going to make a
really intricate design maybe not as
good as illustrator but so is that is
that all the questions here when you ask
it that way it's kind of like our writer
y'all done yet all right well I really
appreciate you all listening to the talk
especially since there are other great
talks going on right now but you'll have
a good day thanks